from the people that you've spoken to or
there's what you've heard through the
grapevine
is it the case that roswell is
not the recovery of balloon debris that
it indeed is some ufo craft that is
either deliberately landed or
or
accidentally landed
okay so that's the that's the question
right so that's um that's the mythology
of prometheus this uh this idea that
somehow we were you know some people
call that site the donation site right
or the gifting site and that's very
promethean that's right along the lines
of this myth and so that's how i felt
very uncomfortable as a person who's
rational
going into basically what looked to be a
living mythology okay a mythology that
was actually people actually were living
and believing it okay
so i'm not going to take the bait and
say that
that's the fact
i don't know if it's the fact
and i know that a lot you know it used
to be that thinking that or just saying
that would would cause one to be called
a quack or something like that right or
you know conspiracy theorists or
something like that believe it or not
the culture has changed so much that now
if you don't believe that people think
you're
bad or wrong or something it seems so no
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna believe or
disbelieve i don't know but i was at one
of those places